HOW MANY I.C.E. DETAIN.
SO CRIMINAL RECORDS CAN BE
RELEASED INTO THE UNITED STATES.
HE RAN CUSTOMS AND BORDER PATROL
UNDER PRESIDENT OBAMA.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR COMING
ON.
SO DEMOCRATS ARE DEMANDING  THAT
I.C.E. CAP BED SPACE, AND
INTERIOR OF THE COUNTRY, NOT THE
BORDERS, IN THE CENTER OF THE
COUNTRY TO, 16,500 A YEAR.
IF THAT WERE TO HAPPEN, WHAT
WOULD IT MEAN?
>> THAT'S A SIGNIFICANT STEP
TOWARDS REALLY ABOLISHING
I.C.E., VEE AT CHECKBOOK.
THERE ARE TWO ELEMENT TO THE
PLAN.
THEY WANT TO ACTUALLY REDUCE
OVERALL BED SPACE FOR I.C.E. AND
END CAP INTERIOR ENFORCEMENT.
WE ALREADY BE THAT IF YOU'RE A
CHILD, A FAMILY UNIT, YOU'RE
GOING TO BE ALLOWED FROM THIS C.
THAT'S CATCH RELEASE 1 POINT 0.
THIS IS CATCH AND RELEASE POINT
0.
IF BED SPACE GOES DOWN, ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION GOES UP.
BORDER PATROL TURNS EVERYBODY WE
APPREHEND OVER TORSI'S.
AS BED SPACE GOES DOWN, THEY'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO RELEASE MORE
INDIVIDUALS INTO THE INTERIOR OF
THE UNITED STATES.
WHAT THAT DOES S FROM A COMMON
SENSE STANDPOINT, THAT MEANS
THAT PEOPLE HERE, THAT ARE HERE
ILLEGALLY, AND HAVE COMMITTED AN
ADDITIONAL CRIME AND OR CHARGE
.
>> WHAT DO THE NUMBERS TELL US.
>> IT'S COMPLETELY FALSE.
SO RIGHT NOW, I.C.E. ALONE, LAST
YEAR, ARREST, I THINK THE NUMBER
IS WELL IN EXCESS OF 120,000
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE HERE
ILLEGALLY, FOR AN ADDITIONAL
CRIME.
RIGHT NOW, THE 45,000 THAT
I.C.E. HAS DETAINED RIGHT
NOW, 70 TO 80% OF THEM, ALMOST,
I THINK ABOUT 85% OF THEM HAVE
BEEN CONVICTED AND OR CHARGED
WITH ANOTHER CRIME BESIDES
ENTERING ILLEGAL LEAST SO THAT'S
A COMPLETE FALSE NARRATIVE.
>> I THINK THE NUMBERS ARE 88%.
THAT WOULD MEAN, JUST TO BE
COMPLETELY CLEAR.
SO A MATH QUESTION F. YOU CAPPED
BED SPACE AT THE THRESHOLD
THEY'RE CALLING FOR.
BY DEFINITION, YOU'D BE
RELEASING CRIMINALS INTO THE
POPULATION.
>> IMMEDIATELY IF THIS BILL
PASSED, THEY WOULD HAVE TO
PROBABLY RELEASE ABOUT 8,000
INDIVIDUALS, CRIMINAL ALIENS AND
IT'S NOT THE CRIME OF ILLEGALLY
ENTERING.
THIS IS CRIMES IN ADDITION TO
THAT.
>> Tucker: SO WHAT PERCENTAGE
SHOULD THE SHOW BACK UP FOR
THEIR HEARINGS, SHOULD SAY.
>> MINISCULE.
>> Tucker: NONE.
THE NUMBER IS 3 PERCENT.
WE CHECKED AND I THINK THOSE
PEOPLE WANDERED IN BY M.
SO BASICALLY, YOU'RE SUSPENDING
THE RULE OF LAW FOR A LARGE
GROUP OF PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN
CHARGED WITH OR CONVICTED OF
CRIMES.
>> YOU'RE REDUCING A BED SPACE.
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION IS
INCREASED, AND NUMBER HAS SHOWN
THAT.
MORE PEOPLE GOING TO BE RELEASED
INTO THE INTERIOR UNITED STATES.
WHAT WE HAVE CREATED HERE IS A
SANCTUARY COUNTRY.
THAT'S WHERE WE'RE HEADED.
>> Tucker: SO IS THERE ANY
SHERIFFS ORGANIZATION, BORDER
PATROL ORGANIZATION, LAW
ENFORCEMENT ORGANIZATION THAT
SUPPORT THIS IS IDEA?
>> I DON'T KNOW OF ONE.
>> Tucker: SO WHERE DID THIS
COME FROM AND WHAT'S THE POINT
OF IT?
WHAT WOULD BE THE GOAL OF THIS?
>> THE GOAL, AND THIS HAS BEEN
TOUGH FOR ME TO GET TO, AND I
DON'T SAY THIS WITH EASE, BUT
THIS IS PURE IDENTITY POLITICS.
I CAN DRAW NO OTHER CONCLUSION
FROM THIS LAST-MINUTE STUNT.
IT'S INSANE, TUCKER, SO IT'S GOT
TO BE DRIVEN BY IDENTITY